When we run the code, we get this output. And
notice how we have friend count split by females, and then
by males. And it looks like the median and the mean
friend count is greater for females. So here the answer was
women. Now the difference between the median friend count for
men and women is 22. That's just subtracting these two numbers.
Now, something I want to draw your attention to is the
mean Notice how the mean for friend count is higher than
the median for both females and for males. This should
make sense since our data is long tailed. So these
higher values out and the higher friend counts our kind of
pull our mean to the right. For this last question,
the median is a better measure than mean because it's
a more robust statistic. A few people with huge friend
counts drag the mean upwards which isn't necessarily representative of
most users. What's nice is that the median's resistant to change,
since it marks the halfway point for all data points. So as long as we trust
half of our values, we can report a
reliable location of the center of our distribution.